[Music]
well this unforgettable song won an
Oscar back in 1988 and we're gonna get
to hear it all over again when the TV
remake of Dirty Dancing airs on ABC two
weeks from today at a whole new cast is
tackling every iconic moment so I
totally get why they were a little bit
nervous on the set but we saw when we
went behind the scenes
it was like oh I want to be fun of me
like baby I want to dance like that
but I'm the most uncoordinated human
being on the face there so didn't seem
like a likely scenario for me 21 year
old abigail breslin dyed her hair and
went from blonde to brunette to play
Jennifer graves baby and we're thinking
those very impressive abs helped Colt
praticed when the part as Patrick
Swayze's Johnny but his biggest fear was
having to say these words nobody puts
Baby I feel like I do it eyebrow just as
naturally as possible say it just say it
nobody puts Baby in a corner
something like that nobody puts Baby in
a corner
that iconic lift was tough for Abigail
who had absolutely no dance experience
she rehearsed it for about eight weeks
before trying it for the first time in
the lake I was terrified I could feel
like my heart racing so much and then
when I was up there and we held it I was
like ah I get it I'm here I wanted to
cry when I saw that they did a lift for
the first time so I've known her since
she was 1 I was 6 and to see her conquer
something like that is is really amazing
Modern Family Sarah Hyland plays older
sister Lisa Nicole Scherzinger is dancer
penny wears green wood is baby's dad
Debra Messing plays her mom from the
dance of the log to Swayze's jump shot
for shot ABC's TV movie is remaking the
original film which is celebrating its
30th anniversary with a special
collector's edition DVD I call this
dirty dancing 2.0 we have a three hour
movie event instead of an
hour-and-a-half feature beau Casper
Smart plays the guy who befriends baby
burger the job well during filming his
ex JLo visited the set and even stay for
an epic one day wearing dance party
that's JLo in the back
she's the Baader and I was like I just
had sushi and had a onesie dance party
with Layla that's pretty chill see I was
really fun
you